hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france a 24 y me acompaña en el estudio
marina sardina marina vamos a hablar de
un tema que está bastante invisibilizado
y son los derechos de la salud de las
mujeres en las prisiones de nuestra
región de américa latina y el caribe es
que el cancelamiento de mujeres en la
región se ha incrementado drásticamente
en las últimas dos décadas marina bueno
es de arrázola así es y esto es
alarmante puesto que los números de
mujeres en prisión están creciendo mucho
más rápido que el de los hombres dejando
patentes múltiples carencias que tienen
los sistemas penitenciarios para el
acceso a la salud con enfoque de género
como es la salud sexual la maternidad o
la salud mental de estas personas en
situación carcelaria veamos algunos
datos de la región las mujeres
representan el menos del 6 9% de la
población carcelaria mundial muchos
países de la región sobrepasan estas
cifras entre el año 2000 y 2017 hubo un
incremento del 53 3% que son muy
desproporcionales al incremento que hubo
de los hombres que aumentaron en un 20%
en el mismo período más de un tercio de
esta población mundial en las américas
siendo el salvador panamá a costa rica
uruguay brasil los países que tienen
mayores tasas de mujeres y niñas en sus
cárceles en américa latina' el principal
delito por el que estas personas están
acusadas está relacionado con delitos de
drogas y rara vez rara vez con delitos
de violencia que ocurre entonces con
este incremento en las cárceles pues son
sistemas que no están diseñados con una
mirada de enfoque feminista por lo tanto
la sobrepoblación el hacinamiento las
carencias que ya sufren en
infraestructura lleva lleva a que las
mujeres sufran mayores violencias dentro
de estos centros este incremento también
se vio durante la pandemia este tipo de
violencias hablamos previamente con
corina ya con ello ella es investigadora
de la universidad autónoma de chiapas
méxico
en las mujeres que llegan a prisión
sufren de mayores problemas de salud
mental y uso problemático de drogas que
las mujeres en el exterior porque vienen
de toda una vida de violencia contra la
infancia y violencia de género contra
las mujeres entonces los problemas de
salud mental y de uso de sustancias son
particularmente graves y el acceso a la
salud per se y salud
a derechos sexuales y reproductivos es
muy precaria por la exclusión en razón
de género que hay de las mujeres
privadas de la libertad en la región
hablamos entonces del papel del estado
marina que deberían garantizar que las
mujeres tengan acceso a una salud sexual
y reproductiva adecuada y otros derechos
a la salud no debería raúl pero lo
cierto es bueno hace una década en
naciones unidas- implementó lo que se
llamó como las reglas de bangkok son
unas 70 directrices para el tratamiento
de las reclusas que dice entre otras
cosas que se debe garantizar todo el
tema de salud en las cárceles de mou de
mujeres basadas en sus necesidades y las
de sus hijos por ejemplo los
alojamientos deben estar destinados y
tienen contar con personal que puedan
satisfacer las necesidades vírgenes
propias como por ejemplo acceso a
toallitas higiénicas y otros productos
de higiene íntima los centros deben
también brindar una atención de la salud
orientados expresamente a las mujeres y
a las mujeres trans como garantizar
también tratamientos médicos para
enfermedades crónicas y de transmisión
sexual como por ejemplo el vih o el
virus del papiloma que si no se tratan
con un ginecólogo y de forma adecuada y
constante pues puede derivar en
enfermedades más graves como cáncer u
otro tipo de problemas la lista de
carencias es larga y de recomendaciones
que hizo la onu con este plan bangkok
sin embargo la falta de personal y de
personal cualificado que atienda este
tipo de necesidades de las mujeres pues
muchas veces queda relegado y se olvida
y acaba afectando a estas reclusos así
es marina es que por lo general también
en nuestra región américa latina y
caribe la asistencia médica es muy
limitada y no contempla resolución y
reproductiva de las mujeres se replica
esa situación en las cárceles si de
hecho es una problemática que se ve
dentro y fuera de las cárceles no muchos
países por ejemplo como el salvador
white y criminalizan a las mujeres por
temas de salud como es el acceso al
aborto entonces al final lo que ocurre
dentro de las cárceles de las prisiones
no deja de ser un reflejo de lo que está
pasando fuera de estos países no de
estas criminalización es por temas de
salud como el este acceso al aborto en
américa latina pues cuentan con grandes
déficit de eficiencias en materia de
derechos sexuales y reproductivos pese a
que muchos países como por ejemplo
colombia despenalizaron el aborto
eso ya está garantizado para las mujeres
dentro de las prisiones los tiempos son
más lentos entonces esto hace pues que
no puedan hacer tan fácilmente que se
les pasen los tiempos y también la falta
de personal la escasez la escasez de
personal pues hace que esto se empeore
también con el tema de la maternidad y
hablamos con corina al respecto
con respecto a la maternidad
generalmente hay una carencia de
servicios pediátricos para las chicas y
los hijos de las mujeres en prisión
el tiempo que pueden permanecer en la
cárcel con sus madres depende de país a
país con un promedio de hasta los 34
años pero una vez más la atención médica
depende mucho de la presión médica que
provee al centro penitenciario que
generalmente es muy básica y con la
escasez de medicamentos y el acceso a
los convenios con el sistema de salud
externo pues generalmente el acceso a la
salud es uno de los ámbitos más
problemáticos en el sistema
penitenciario para todo el mundo para
mujeres mujeres trans y niñas y niños
obviamente esto se agudiza algo muy
importante marina qué sucede con la
salud mental de las mujeres privadas de
libertad
bueno la salud mental de estas mujeres
se ve gravemente impactada dentro de las
prisiones y es que muchas veces cuentan
con problemas de adicción a sustancias
que no son tratadas y que no están
dentro de los centros penitenciarios no
encuentran con con programas de
rehabilitación adecuados para este tipo
de personas también ante una falta de
atención psicológica adecuada termina
llevando a que las reclusas pues que se
hagan una sobre medicación o hiper
medicación como nos contó corina
otro tema que hay que tomar en cuenta es
que en la américa latina en la carencia
generalizada de servicio a tratamiento
de adicciones lo cual una vez más se
recrudecen las prisiones un punto muy
importante que haces en tu pregunta es
el tema de acceso al medicamento de tipo
psiquiátrico en las prisiones justamente
pasa poco al revés o sea las personas
llegan con problemas importantes de
salud mental y de uso de sustancias y la
respuesta que hay es una hiper
medicación no a falta de acceso a
tratamientos de tipo más psicológico
[Música]
digamos se colma esa carencia con un
híper uso de medicamentos psiquiátricos
y también lo que hacen es mantener la
población controlada y raúl lo que hacen
las organizaciones y lo que piden es un
mayor mayores accesos a este tipo de
salud y también piden lo primero es de
despoblar las prisiones implementar
políticas con un enfoque de género de
estas dentro de las cárceles basadas en
un criterio de derechos humanos y de
salud pública y es que también hay que
tener en cuenta las vulnerabilidades y
discriminaciones múltiples de las
mujeres pues que son intencionales como
la pobreza los colectivos lgtb
plus más que muy grandes afro indígenas
y es que las mayorías de las cárceles
están copadas por mujeres empobrecidas
que estoy bien sufren violencia fuera de
las cárceles se agrava dentro de las
prisiones gracias.marina como siempre
por toda la información de salud en
directo américa de francés de cuatro
pasamos a saludar ahora a nuestro
invitado el día